Alright, welcome to
my "Quiplash" game.
Tonight we're playing with
Kenan Thompson,
Whitney Cummings,
and Melissa Villaseñor!
-Whoo-whoo!
-Thank you, guys, so much
for playing this.
Here's how the game works
for everyone at home.
On our phones we're going to
get a series of
fill-in-the-blank style
prompts like,
"A good name for a pirate
singles bar is blank."
Then we'll each secretly type on
our phone the funniest answer
that we can think of
on the spot.
When we're done, two answers
will go head-to-head
on the screen and the other
players will vote
for whichever answer
they think is funnier.
The more votes your answer gets,
the more points you get.
But we won't know whose answer
it is until after we vote.
-I'm so confused.
I'm so confused.
-You ready?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm lost. I'm so lost.
-Alright, do you guys
have your devices?
-Yes.
-Everyone can play this at home.
Not right now, but you can play
your own version of the game.
Alright, let's start the game.
Let's "Quiplash"!
Alright, everybody in?
Here we go, guys.
Good luck to everyone.
This is our "Quiplash."
Here we go.
-Let's do it.
-Alright, now you get a question
on your phone
that no one else can see,
so you just answer the questions
that come on your phone screen.
For people at home,
I'll fast-forward this part
so it won't be as boring.
Alright.
-Ah, okay.
-Round one guys.
Good luck. Here we go!
Round one! I'm feeling good!
Alright.
-I'm nervous!
-Me too. So am I. I'm sweating.
♪♪
I mean, how mean are we
allowed to be here?
[ Laughs ]
Melissa!
-You know what?
I love this game.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. Everyone's in!
Everyone's in!
Alright, come on.
-Okay, okay.
-Alright, here we go.
Everyone's answers are locked.
We don't know. Here we go.
And this is the game "Quiplash."
Alright, "The Wright Brothers'
first words after flying
for the first time were..."
"Damn, Daniel."
[ Laughter ]
Or "I got to change my undies."
-Damn, Daniel.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright.
I knew I got --
No one even remembers.
-Whoo-hoo! Kenan!
-No one remembers
"Damn, Daniel!"
-I remember "Damn, Daniel."
That's a good one.
-"Alvin and the Chipmunks 12."
Get out of my undies,
you chipmunks."
-Lot of undies talk.
-I know.
-"Even more buck."
Is buck --
-Like buckteeth?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I thought that was
a character from the movie.
I thought Buck was the manager.
-Oh, it's a --
-It's a 50/50 split.
Nice.
-Close game.
No love for me yet.
"A good way to get kicked out of
a jazz band"?
"Blessing the audience
with sax spit."
[ Laughter ]
-In this climate?
-"Show your pee-pee
in the recording studio."
[ Laughter ]
You'll get kicked out.
You can't do that.
-A pee-pee?
-Yeah.
-Pee-pee.
-Is that a baby?
[ Laughter ]
-Everybody staying away
from my pee-pee.
-It's a close quip right now.
-Okay.
-Oh, snap.
-Ooh, look at this,
Kenan in the lead. Mad dog.
-Keep it going.
Hoo, hoo, hoo.
-Kenan's back. He's back.
He's back.
-He's barking. Oh, my God.
Ridiculous.
Round two, here we go.
Look at your question
on your phone.
Oh, my God.
-Oh, that is a corny one.
I just put in a real corny one.
-So did I. So did I.
-You're allowed to.
You're allowed to.
Answers are in.
Round two, "Surprising photos to
find on Garfield's phone
would be of..."
"A corpse."
[ Laughter ]
"Odie's butt."
Oh, my gosh.
-It's 50/50.
A corpse is great.
-That's so funny.
That's so dark.
-"The nickname Van Gogh gave
his remaining ear."
-Get ready for the corn.
-"Han Solo."
"Richard G-Ear."
-Richard G-Ear.
[ Laughter ]
-Richard G-Ear -- I feel like
that's going to win.
-That was good.
-Richard G-Ear.
You're allowed to do
those ones, man.
You know they're going to
get the votes.
-Yeah. Totally.
That made me hate myself
writing it in, but...
-Hey, man, we got to win here.
Here we go.
Current score after round two,
it looks like --
-Ooh.
-Oh!
-Come on now.
-It's rigged!
-Here we go.
It's not rigged.
-God.
-Round three is the last lash,
and we're never doing this game
ever again.
Whoever wins, wins forever.
-I'm into this game now.
-Acro-Lash, here we go.
Last lash goes like this.
Come up with a full name
for this acronym.
"M-E-M," full name.
♪♪
-Mine's not even
a real sentence.
♪♪
-Oh, no, I can't even write it.
-I don't even know
what I'm doing.
-We have 15 seconds left.
Oh, no.
-15 seconds, come on.
♪♪
-Rudy! Rudy! Rudy!
-Come on, come on, come on.
-3, 2, 1.
-Oh, gosh.
-Okay, soak it in.
-Full name for this acronym.
"Mom eats meth."
"My end is M."
"Marvin Ewing Marvin."
-[ Laughs ]
-"Make every money."
MEM stands for "Mom eats meth."
"Marvin Ewing Marvin."
I think they switched it up
a little bit
by naming the middle name Ewing.
"My end is M"
and "Make every money."
[ Laughs ]
Did everyone vote?
-Yep.
-6 seconds left.
-Oh, I think I did.
-Alright, here we go, guys.
I couldn't come up with --
my end is --
I couldn't think of anything.
Thank you for giving me
that silver.
-Oh, look at -- Gosh.
-Oh, look at Whitney.
-Whitney crushed.
-Mom eats meth.
-That's just my childhood.
-"Mom eats meth"
crushed on that one.
Whitney Cummings for the win.
Let's see the final tally
right here, guys.
-It's going to be Whitney,
right?
-This is for everything.
Come on. No, no. It's close.
-Oh!
-Oh, my gosh!
-So close!
-Crazy.
-Oh, my goodness!
I love you guys.
Thank you so much.
Kenan, Whitney Cummings,
Melissa Villaseñor.
Thank you
for playing "Quiplash" guys.
-That was amazing.
-Made a lot of money
for Red Cross, guys.
Thank you so much.